first one we've we've run online we
actually uh
on the the last meeting it was just
before coverage started so this is the
first
online meeting that we're going to have
um
just a couple of quick housekeeping
things i mean this
this meeting is is going to be webcast
and it will be filmed for live and
subsequent broadcast
on the council's youtube channel
a whole meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or
exempt items make a representation
to the meeting you'll be teamed up
consented to being filmed
do not wish to have your image captured
if you have any queries regarding
webcasting or
of meetings please contact the contact
the governance officer
at democratic services
uh just the other bit of housekeeping is
if anyone's got any
uh question to raise please the raised
hand facility
which i make sure that it comes to
people in order
so um sorry all your questions are
answered
um an order of the hands being raised
so just moving on to
the gender first item is attendances
i know we've had apologies from uh
councillor hartley
anthony wooden and mr griffiths
who have any more people giving
apologies to this meeting
again thank you for your attendances
quite a good good turnout for this time
of day
uh moving on to minutes
so to receive the minutes of the meeting
held on the 4th of march
which as i said shortly it was the just
before the pandemic
sort of kicked in so it was the last
physical meeting that we
we had and this is our first
virtual meeting anyone with any comments
or
things they'd like to raise about the
previous minutes that was some time ago
if not we'll agree those is a true
record
um
okay and
moving on to the urgent business
not aware of any urgent business this
meeting
item 4 which is the
cpl 15 areas of best practice
and the impact of kobe 19.
so this is um the in-depth review
of the uh standard for local authorities
in 2018.
people remember we did discuss this at
the the meeting in march
um and this is really to to give an
update
report from the officer um
about the council's progress um and
particularly in light of the
kobe 19 pandemic just uh
sort of a quick comment about it i think
most items of the best practice have
been
either completed or been delayed
because of postponement to er
of the council meetings and in a couple
of cases
accounts and audit so that's the main
reason why some of the
items haven't been finally completed
um a couple of items
you'll note about the progress 2 related
to the parish council
which haven't been finalized as yet so
they
they need to be completed we will have
to report
back um about our progress on these
items but as i say
most of the items have been completed
or will be completed shortly um
due to sort of delays with the
administration through
council meetings being delayed i don't
know if jane's got anything further to
add to that
um um no really i can just
confirm that the case um the the the
main step required to be followed with
the
implementation of the changes to the um
constitution to accommodate
the code um and other steps and
because we've not had a council meeting
throughout this
period it's not been possible obviously
to make those
changes there is a council meeting next
week
but we also have some further changes
that are required to
um and are coming through they have come
through the employment committee so
we're rolling up all the changes
and they'll be reported on to the
council meeting
in october so they'll be put into effect
at that
point in time um the parish council one
is
simply because it's difficult to arrange
um
the the meetings that we need to arrange
to just sort of discuss
the changes with them and the other
changes the
um is in respect to the annual uh
governance statement
um and again that's been deferred
because um accounts committee
um the the actual um date
the completion of the annual governor's
statement
was deferred by um
nationally effectively until later this
year so
and we will receive a request in the
autumn asking for us to report back as
to
um where we sit in terms of the
implementation of those 15
recommendations so unless anybody has
any questions i think that
hopefully sums the position up okay
council blackberry wanted to make a
comment
yeah i just wanted to ask please um
has the parish council or will the
parish council
be having a zoo meeting as as we do for
for our committees
um or will it will sort of decisions
um i think item 11 and 12 on the on the
report
will that just be dealt with when the
time comes that they do have a meeting
or
are able to get together
on mute again um in in terms of the
council meetings it's a matter for them
as to how they actually
conduct their meetings the meetings that
are proposed and that are
referenced in the report are actually
informal meetings and it's for us
to explore with them how they may wish
to change vegetables about the way in
which they
conduct their business so it's not uh
and again there's nothing mandatory
about
them being quite i understand
the position but it's simply that we've
not um been
able to um initiate those discussions as
yet
i'm sure we will get this resolved
sooner rather than later
and hopefully we will in the not too
distant future
i think um councillor walsh you had a
yes yes um possibly related to what
councillor black burns just said
um what we're going to be doing is
asking the parish the four parish
councils how we can
support them and so because of
things have been put back we're going to
be asking them that
together with talking to them about
proposals for the
boundary commission changes
when i was reading the agency so i just
thought that
those are quite big big items i think
really i'm just wondering if
if we were to sit down in a meeting or
officer sat down in a meeting with the
parish councils
with those two things on the agenda you
know that
they perhaps deserve discussions
for an even in their own right do you
know i mean i'm just worried about them
being diluted and
not given the scrutiny perhaps they
deserve i don't know what
you think cheryl uh miss leferve thinks
i i i take your point i mean it's it's
something that hasn't come up previously
and obviously we
previously looked at the steps that were
required to be taken in respect to the
parish
councils um but i'm quite
happy to um take away
um a perhaps consider how we we can look
at how it's been dealt with elsewhere
um um and and how they've approached
this particular
um issue um i i i would
it's possible that uh one of the members
on the committee here that
nicole jackson might have some i don't
know whether you've been involved in it
in this aspect of it in one of your
other
committee roles as an independent person
or chair
i'll just unmute myself um sorry i don't
think i've met most members because i
never seem to be able to uh to get to a
meeting
um i'm nicola jackson um
i didn't i just sort of introduced you
separately do you apologize for that no
it's okay
so sorry what was the question how
how we can should i should i shall i
speak chair
should like trying to explain to nicola
repeat it again yeah so
so what was saying in in the uh when i
was reading the agenda nicola was that
we're going to be asking the parish
councils how we can
support the parish councils better how
traffic can support the parish council
but we're also going to be saying to
them at the same time because of covert
and things have been put back
we're also going to be asking them about
what they think about the boundary
changes what the boundary commission are
proposing
for the wards and in the borough and i
just thought
when i read it i just thought those are
quite big meaty issues to be discussing
together and that the parish councils
might want to sort of look at them
you know quite separately um i don't
know what you think
um it it's not come up at any of the
other
three standards committees that i'm
involved with um but partly because i
think certainly one if not two have not
got any parish councils
um my experience in my previous life as
a monitoring officer
was that parish councils um need quite a
lot of support in terms of
standards matters and sort of code of
conduct matters
and i do think it will be preferable to
split the two
subjects yeah um because it's
for a lot of parish councils the whole
sort of regime of
the members code of conduct and the and
the arrangements that have to go into
in place seems extremely onerous
until they've got the the sort of
systems in place once they've got the
systems in place then it's normally
quite okay and you can have a once
you've done training for them you can
have a quite light
touch approach to the parish councils as
long as the um parish councils know that
they
they've got you know a sort of
relationship with the monitoring officer
and can and can contact them but i think
that
um certainly that my previous experience
as an mo
was that code of conduct the whole
subject of code of conduct by itself
is a biggie um and i think to lump the
two together
that and the boundary review um
would be too much yeah thank you
oh well thank you for that i think we'll
we'll take those comments on board and
obviously that'll be
considered when we were making the
necessary arrangements
uh any more questions comments on this
this matter
no okay we'll move on to
item five the lga model code of conduct
this was brought in
in may which is a very unfortunate time
um the pandemic really kicking
in um and it's basically
looking at the model code of conduct
um for members and comparing this with
what we need to do is compare this with
what happens in trafford in my view is
that
it's very similar to what we do already
in trafford
uh although perhaps what we do is a bit
more specific
in terms of the the policy um
there is actually going to be a final
version in the
lga towards the end of the year so i
think the plan would be
to look at that and finalize it after
that
that comes forward um
so really just one final point to
mention is
this is just for guidance owner and we
can you know
adopt things and adapt things to this is
is completely different to that but
obviously it's something that we need to
consider
and look at and uh maybe
revise our policy if we feel that that's
appropriate
anything further just to answer that
jane yeah i said
that's a good summary of where we are
with this i mean this is
um the report before you tonight is for
noting to say unfortunately when they
um produce the model code for
consultation although it
was circulated um reasonably
widely i think it went under the radar
for quite a lot of
people um given that we were very much
in the throes of the
pandemic at that time and i think there
were
several um joint responses sent i know
we
submitted a response um from the chief
legal officers
monitoring officers across gm
but there was no standards committee in
that
time and we were not in a position to so
it's not
actually been before you for
consideration at that
stage so it's really to note where they
are with this at this point
they are producing a further um
version of the code which we will have
an opportunity to review
and as um said this is um
advisory only our current code is
based um largely upon the previous
version of the lga model code of conduct
doesn't follow it exactly and so what
we're proposing is that this is here so
that you can see
what they are suggesting at this point
in time and when the
code is finalized um at the
later on in this year and what we're
supposed to do is to bring you back a
more detailed examination
of the two so you can see where they
compare and contrast
and consider how you may wish
to amend our current code if you do wish
to amend it
which points we do need to take in to
cover the changes um
that that we feel are appropriate as a
result of this
um new amended version so um
i don't think i can really sort of say
anything more honest at this stage it's
there
largely to keep you informed as to where
um
this document is in terms of its
progress
i suppose the other point is obviously
we're learning a new world now so there
may be some
things in the the way we working and
and living now that might change the
procedure probably looking at it
probably that out much but they maybe
wanted to
do things anybody got any comments or
questions
please
[Music]
paragraph two five you talk about except
in relation to
uh breach sanctions for breaches where
we
we are silent uh as opposed to the model
code as something to say
but we intend to
i i it's not something obviously we've
i think we've discussed this previously
um uh
earlier this year in relation to
sanctions because
say our bar code is silent um
and previously there had not been any
specific guidance around that now
this code is quite specific in setting
out was dividing
gail effectively of sanctions and and
i would suggest that it is something
that is worthy of
um uh consideration um
when the code comes back before you
later
in the in the air to consider whether or
not that would be appropriate
for inclusion it would definitely help
to give some peace to what
otherwise might seem quite a um
a powerless weapon in some respect
um because it doesn't give us any real
guidance
when members might play off the uh
um yes i think it would be well worthy
of consideration
councilmembers you've got a comment
uh yes thank you chairman that's a
question for the borough sister really
are there any um there's two
very detailed codes here but are there
any substantive differences that you're
aware of between the two codes that we
need to
consider before formally um accepting
one or the other
um no there's i don't think there are
any substantive
differences there are more differences
of form rather than content i think with
much of it
um but in any event as i say this isn't
the final document we are expecting a
further
um uh uh version uh which will pick up
points that may have come out of the
consultations
and when it comes to you to look at
again
then we will do a very detailed compare
and contrast
so that you can see exactly where those
changes are
and we can consider it in some detail
before
you consider what you might wish to
recommend to counsel
for adoption okay thank you
uh mr brown you had a question
yeah i think i didn't quite hear
everything that david said but i think
it does relate to this internal
resolution procedure
um and i i think james just just covered
um that my concern a little bit was the
um the sliding scale
um and it seems that even for quite
serious breaches
the uh the most serious sanction
is a um a bar on attendance
at um committees for two months i just
wondered
um that seems
if if there's a very serious breach that
what happens beyond there because it
looks like that there's a
a two month um period where an
individual would
would um would maybe face some sanctions
but after that
um there wouldn't be anything um i just
i know that there's probably
opportunities to come back and look at
this but uh
it it seems strange i just wondered what
what the view was of that
um again i think it it's all um
indicative of the fact that the the
legislation that sort of this is all
based on doesn't give us any particular
powers
um there's the sanctions there are not
um as you say particularly strong um
in respect of the more serious breaches
that
might arise um i think it's something
that has been
raised through the consultation so
whether it will give rise to any
um additional um measures being
proposed um
we will have to wait and see um i know
that there are some
authorities that use other types of
sanctions on an informal
basis um
but they're not always that successful
and they're not always
um free from uh risk of challenge either
um for example they'll withdraw things
like um
the right to use um council services but
then
that interferes with the individual's
eligibility ability to
um function as a um as a representative
for their
um awards so it it's very difficult
but it will be interesting to see
whether there are
any further proposals that come out of
the
consultation because i know it is an
area which has
exercised a lot of people over the time
can i just come back on that because it
does
obviously contain that the claws there
about the non-criminal breach so
obviously if there's a a criminal
elements
to to the breach then that will be dealt
with separately
it just does leave that that scenario
where somebody
um after two months could be back on
committees and everyone feeling very
very uncomfortable with that scenario um
where there's been a very serious breach
so yeah thank you thank you for
answering my question
okay thank you um counselor you had a
question yeah um thanks chad uh i'm just
going to say i i'd agreed with with
david
you might say the best of both don't you
what's good in our
uh procedures and what's good in the
lga's
procedures and i just thought these were
talking about hospitality
25 pounds seems like a reasonable gift
to me that
that needs to be declared and uh whereas
the uh
the code of conduct proposes is a
hundred pounds
when we get to that stage at a later
meeting just discussing the um
the way we're going to go i i would be
looking to keep the 25 pound uh
amount that that people should be
declaring and um
like david said i'd wrote it down
include the resolution procedure and
propose sanctions which
which we've not got in our model code of
conduct so you
we wanted to be taking the best of um
both worlds and then and
um again like
i said earlier it needs a proper
discussion we need to go through them
the previous speaker richard spoke about
the two-month sanction well that's
neither here in the there isn't it so it
all needs examining chair but
i'm aware that when we're not at that
stage yet thank you thank you
well i will obviously get to that point
when we get the final version
uh counselor uh coggins you had a
question
it's just a minor comment calling up on
richard's point that of course
um lots of cancers aren't on any
committees and lots of committees meet
less than two monthly so in fact there's
effectively
no um uh no impact of of of that rule in
a lot of cases just to point that out
okay thank you
okay any more questions comments
well the report is is for noting so
we'll do that and we obviously will
revisit this um we're probably talking
uh
early next year i think um so yeah
further discussions will be had on this
uh
okay moving on to item number six
uh this is dispensation to the six
months
attendance rule um obviously this was
brought in
because of the pandemic that we required
to
change the timings of and initially to
postpone a lot of our meetings and then
change the timings of them
which made it very difficult for many um
memory members to
actually attend uh because usually
because of work commitments
so um we we did bring in this
facility and the number as you'll see
from report a number of um
exemptions have had been granted um
for a number of councillors as you will
see there on that a couple of councils
which are
close to that point um the point here
though is that um
the calendar meetings uh are gonna
be set up for the uh council meetings
running in september october and
november
so that the councils will have
opportunity
to um attend those meetings out of
work hours because they'll be running at
7pm
so hopefully this this issue will be
less of a problem
moving forward um but we will
obviously continue to provide that
assistance if councils have difficulty
did you want to comment anything further
on this james
i know it's actually quite a bit of work
for your team into the administration
so that's a factor but um it's fine
it's fine um uh and it beats having to
call a council meeting on each occasion
to deal with them which would be the
only other way that we could have
could have done this um uh
but um as it says in the report we and
as you mentioned we have
got council meetings um which we've
scheduled
for the normal uh start time of seven
o'clock uh whilst the proposal is still
that we retain
um other meetings at this earlier start
time of four or
four o'clock um while we're um still
working through the current restrictions
um but hopefully the fact that we have
uh full council meetings
uh three of them now um through the rest
of the year will enable
members to engage more effectively
i know that there's been some concerns
raised as well about the fact that
the way that our website currently
records
um attendances and absences
and the fact that um some members feel
uncomfortable about the fact that
they're just shown us not having
attended
meetings so we are looking at the way in
which perhaps that can be
um denoted on the website so it's quite
clear
that there was um a legitimate
reason for for non-attendance that it's
not since it won't
reflect badly on in individual members
who
have perhaps not been able to attend
meetings as they would have done
otherwise
um because of um the change in time
and their inability to um
[Music]
get uh release from their probably key
uh worker roles to be able to attend
um those meetings yeah i know it has
been it's been very difficult for
quite a few accounts as i know to
actually um
go to meetings outside their working
hours and
i think it's good that we're being able
to support that really and
being able to make this this this ruling
so it's
i think it's you know it's appreciated
and it should continue
anyone wish to make any comments at all
this was um just for noting um
report watch was noting so we've we've
done that
obviously probably pick it up at some
point later in the future
um moving on to the
monitors offering officers report
um i'm sorry i don't really have
anything to report to you
um uh it has been a very strange um
uh uh six months in many respects and
um and obviously we've um had to look at
um changes to the way in which we run
our meetings um and
we've made uh consequential changes
to um our arrangements in that respect
um but in terms of
uh standards matters more more generally
there
um it has been a quiet
six months i would um say
um i think we have one very minor um
allegation which is in the very early
stages of us sort of looking at it we
just acknowledged it which will
um require consideration but other than
that we've had
um no um
no complaints there's been a delay as i
say to the completion of the annual
governance
statement um as a result of covid
um but other than that um
i don't have anything um significant
um or otherwise uh to report to you i'm
afraid
that's probably a good thing um
yeah very difficult times for all of us
um
and it's good that there's been no
issues i've cropped up to
during that period anybody wish to make
any
comments on that any questions
that's the end of the meeting um just
like to thank you all for your
attendance um
i'll see ya time of the day for many
people to
come to the meeting so it's the the good
attendance is
is appreciated um
but we we do obviously want to make uh
acknowledgement of the difficulties that
many councils do have in
an attending uh meetings at this
particular time so
i think we we need to be fully aware of
that
um thank you for your attendances and
hopefully you'll
everybody stay safe take care
thank you thank you bye bye bye bye
thank you